detectives say that they are very close
to solving the cold case murder
of an up-and-coming hip-hop producer his
name is kevin robert harris
that was his name the second he was shot
dead outside a los angeles music studio
this was back in 2009 and kevin robert
harris was only 21 years old cbs this
morning saturday co-host michelle miller
got an inside look at the investigation
for tonight's 48 hours suspicion
on the morning kevin harris was murdered
he had a premonition
he told his mom catherine he said
everything's just happening so
fast i feel like something's going to
happen i said don't think like
that kevin was a musician
a rising young producer in the los
angeles world of hip-hop
this is his music you're hearing in this
piece
he just sold a track to music legend ice
cube
and his family says that britney spears
and rihanna were interested in working
with him
but that never happened in september of
2009
he was gunned down in his car alone
outside a recording studio near lax
his dad also named kevin 10 to 17 shots
two different handguns how much do you
have to kill him
kevin's mom and dad arrived at the crime
scene
about three hours after the shooting
they say the police
were already gone catherine took what
was left behind
i wiped the blood up off the street and
the glass from his window was on the
ground
and i used my hands as a broom to gather
the glass kevin's case
quickly went cold and now 11 years later
the fbi is involved
the clues are absolutely out there we
just need that one piece that one
smoking gun oh wow michelle you feel
really feel for the harris family this
has been so long ago
why has it taken the police so long to
to follow up on this case or
now you're saying that there are leads
in the case well
they've been working on it for the past
11 years about five years ago the fbi
got involved and in fact there has been
an arrest
in this case but investigators say it
just did not that suspect did not cross
the threshold a reasonable doubt they
just need one
piece one piece of this puzzle
to get them over they say they're 80
percent there they're hoping this
broadcast
will give them that development that
will take it over the finish line boy
michelle is so young and so talented i'm
glad you're doing this story because
somebody out there knows something
thank you thank you very much you can
see michelle's report tonight it's
called the ambush of kevin harris
it's on 48 hours suspicion it starts at
10 9 central
here on cbs